Hello Freak bitches.
So it's a great,
it's the idea of infinite universes,
saddened to people.
You know what,
it just,
when something looks that big,
it makes people depressed.
Now when you tell people like maybe there are infinite lives that we are all
living,
you know,
all consecutively,
all right next to each other and they're all completely different.
The idea that I was like,
oh,
it's like I am just barely getting through the pack.
The fact that,
um,
you know,
living here in America on earth in 2010,
I'm barely,
barely wrapping my head around that.
The idea that there's billions and billions and then that we're going to Redo
this every 15 billion years because it's going to be a new big bang and people
are going to eventually evolve out of Amoebas and fish and fucking lizards and
rabbits and monkeys and humans.
Really.
It just keeps going over and over and over and over and over and over again.
Can I tell you my new theory of reincarnation?
Yes.
And it's really intense because I thought at this and it freaked me out.
It's pretty horrible.
So it's like the common idea of reincarnation.
If you subscribe to the theory is that you die and you're born again.
You go through your childhood,
did you grow up and then you die.
Maybe you get born as a cat,
maybe a butterfly,
right?
Maybe an Amoeba.
This is what I was thinking.
Cause I had a dream months and in this dream I was a kid,
a little girl,
and my mom was rubbing my head and I knew I was dying,
but I didn't know what that meant except I knew it was bad and I could kind of
feel myself fading out there is this like white sort of thing happening?
And then I woke up out of the dream like,
fuck,
what is shitty dream?
So I was thinking like,
Oh fuck,
what if that's what reincarnation is?
What if when you die,
you know when you're driving home one night you've had too many pot lollipops.
You're listening to coast to coast.
Someone says something shocking that makes you look away from the road.
You swerve off,
you slam into a tree,
you wake up,
you're here back in your house.
Like,
Oh fuck,
what is shitty dream,
but you've really died.
You just reincarnated again into an ultimate reality in an alternate reality,
so you literally can't die.
There's no break.
This just goes on forever and ever and ever and ever.
No break,
no stopping,
no new age.
Going into the light and seeing your parents and your family and taking a,
going to some new age,
a cosmic spa where you get to shake off all your shitty Karma.
It never stops.
It just keeps happening again.
Again,
maybe like right now there's an earthquake and the ceiling collapses and all of
a sudden you're just some daydreaming cabby and Boston like,
wow,
that was fucking weird.
I was just imagining I was a comedian in la,
but you know what I mean?
Well,
that's bizarre.
You're going to change lives.
Snap into another role to become the guy rides this body out.
Yeah.
You snap it into an alternate life with all your memories.
Embedded everything already embedded in there because it's an infinite,
it's an infinite.
This,
the the,
it goes on forever.
What if your consciousness is living a bunch of different lives simultaneously
and you just can't,
you can't see them.
It's like a,
an office filled with cubicles and no one's poking their head over the top of
the cubicle.
Yeah,
right.
We're all rolling at the same time.
Or like the way I thought about it is like if you're,
if there was like some,
this,
it sounds really crazy,
but imagine that each of your fingers,
it sounds insane,
but imagine like each of your fingers had their own personality and their own
like consciousness or something.
It's like,
and you could stick them through some kind of hole where they would forget they
were attached to your hand and they would just think that they were their own
individual selves.
You know what I mean?
Like maybe that's what we are.
We're just like little fingers protruding into this dimension from some infinite
thing,
but the product of protruding into this dimension as we get instantaneous
amnesia and part of like dealing with a shock of coming into this dimension is
we forget our true identity and replace it with our ego structures.
Wow.
Well.
One of the things that,
yes,
[inaudible].